I KNOW!
WE GOT AN EXTRA DAY OF
NOTHING!
SO, REMEMBER A FEW MONTHS
BACK WHEN JOE ROGAN GOT
COVID AND THE MEDIA'S LYING
D-BAGS CLAIMED HE TOOK HORSE
PILLS.
SORRY, DID I SAY LYING
D-BAGS?
I MEAN STUPID LYING D-BAGS.
>> CAN YOU BELIEVE, LIKE,
JOE ROGAN?
HE'S EATING DEWORMERS.
>> HE SAYS HE'S TAKING
SEVERAL MEDICATIONS
INCLUDING A DRUG MEANT FOR
DEWORMING LIVESTOCK.
>> IN CASE YOU MISSED IT,
ROGAN SAID THE WORD
IVERMECTIN, THE DEWORMING
MEDICINE MADE TO KILL
PARASITES AND DEWORM
ANIMALS.
>> THIS MEDICATION CAUSES
SOME PEOPLE IN THIS CRAZED
ENVIRONMENT WE'RE IN TO WANT
TO TRY IT.
THAT'S THE UPSIDE-DOWN WORLD
WE'RE IN WITH FIGURES LIKE
JOE ROGAN.
>> Greg: [BLEEP].
SORRY!
HORSE PILLS?
MORE LIKE HORSE [BLEEP]!
OF COURSE, IVERMECTIN'S BEEN
APPROVED FOR HUMAN USE FOR
DECADES.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO GET
EVERYTHING WRONG.
THEY COULD DIAGNOSE WHAT
ROGAN NUTS HIS MOUTH AND
MISS EVERYTHING THAT COMES
OUT OF CHRIS CUOMO'S.
IT'S IRONIC DELTA WOULD BE
CRITICAL OF ANYONE ABOUT
COVID GIVEN HE'S A WALKING
RISK FACTOR FOR EVERY
MEDICAL CONDITION ON EARTH.
HE'S A PETRI DISH WEARING
EXTRA LARGE SWEAT PANTS.
HE NEEDS TO MASK UP TO LIMIT
HIS EXPOSURE TO CINNABON.
WHOSE ADVICE WOULD YOU
RATHER TAKE?
ROGAN WHO'S BUILT LIKE A
BRICK WALL OR STELTER BUILT
LIKE AN UNRIPE AVOCADO.
SAD, THE RIDICULE WAS BASED
ON A LIE.
ONE THEY NEVER RESCINDED.
ROGAN CALLED OUT ON HIS OWN
MEDICAL EXPERT.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT WAS A
PROBLEM THAT YOUR NEWS
NETWORK LIES?
>> DUDE, WHAT DID THEY SAY?
>> THEY LIED I WAS TAKING
HORSE DEWORMERS.
DOES BOTHER YOU THE NEWS
NETWORK THAT YOU WORK FOR
OUT-AND-OUT LIED, OUTRIGHT
LIED ABOUT ME TAKING HORSE
DEWORMER.
>> THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID
THAT.
>> WHY'D THEY DO THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Greg: BEING THE MEDICAL
EXPERT AT CNN IS LIKE BEING
AN EXECUTIVE CHEF AT A
PRISON.
IT'S A NICE TITLE BUT
YOU WON'T PUT IT ON YOUR
TINDER PROFILE.
MONTHS LATER, JOE JOINED
SPOTIFY AND THE COVID LIES
CAME BACK IN THE LAST-DITCH
EFFORT TO STAY RELEVANT,
JONI MITCHELL DEMANDED
SPOTIFY DUMP ROGAN.
JONI MITCHELL MAY HAVE LIVED
IN A GARBAGE CAN SINCE THE
1970'S.
THEY WENT FROM SELLING OUT
ARENAS TO JUST SELLING OUT.
BUT IF YOU AREN'T FAMILIAR
WITH NEIL YOUNG OR JONI
MITCHELL, HERE IS A CLIP OF
THEIR CLASSIC.
THEY'RE BOTH FROM CANADA, BY
THE WAY.
MUST BE SOMETHING IN THE
WATER UP THERE.
JUDGING BY THEIR VOICES,
IT'S RAZOR BLADES.
SPOTIFY SHUT DOWN THE
WHINING OLD MARCHES UNTIL
THE SINGERS REMOVE THEIR
CATALOGS FROM SPOTIFY.
HOW DID USERS REACT?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
OF COURSE, DURING ALL THIS,
HOW DID WE COVER IT?
THE ROGAN STORY GOT
WIDESPREAD MEDIA COVERAGE,
FAR MORE COVERAGE THAN HOW
SMALL THE RISK POSES FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE PLACES LIKE CNN
JEALOUS ROGAN OFTEN HAS MORE
INFLUENCE THAN THEY DO.
THEY DON'T LIKE HIS
DANGEROUS IDEAS ABOUT FREE
SPEECH, EXERCISE AND GOD
FORBID CRACKING JOKES.
THERE'S LIKELY NO PERSON ON
EARTH WHO IS DOING MORE TO
DISMANTLE SEGREGATION THAN
HIM.
THE ROSTER OF HIS GUESTS ARE
MORE DIVERSE THAN THE
OLYMPIC OPENING CEREMONIES
AND THEY'RE ALLOWED TO SPEAK
ENDLESSLY ABOUT WHATEVER SO
THE LISTENER CAN DECIDE.
IT'S THE ANTIDOTE TO CABLE
TV WHERE SHOWS RELY ON THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO SAY THE SAME
THINGS OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND NO WONDER CNN HATES
ROGAN, HE'S WIDENED THE
UNIVERSE AS THEY SHRINK IT.
I BELIEVE I'M THE TRUE HERO.
I HEARD ROGAN HAS A BRONZE
BUT OF ME RIGHT NEXT TO THE
BONG.
THERE HE IS JUST TUESDAY ON
HIS PODCAST WHERE HE CLAIMS
FOX AND OTHERS HAD HIS BACK.
>> WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
THAT IF YOU LOOK BACK ON THE
EARLY DAYS THAT WE USED TO
THINK OF AS CONSERVATIVE
VERSUS LIBERAL.
LIBERAL WAS PRO-FREE SPEECH.
PEOPLE WERE OPEN-MINDED,
NONVIOLENT, YOU KNOW, AND
PEOPLE WERE OPEN TO OTHER
PEOPLE'S IDEAS, AND THE
RIGHT WAS LIKE EXPRESSIVE --
SUPPRESSIVE, YOU KNOW, NANNY
STATE, YOU KNOW, CONDEMN
CERTAIN LANGUAGE, CONDEMN
CERTAIN BEHAVIORS.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE TODAY.
>> YEAH.
>> TODAY, THE LEFT HAS GONE
SO [BLEEP] FAR LEFT.
>> Greg: THAT SOUNDS
REALLY FAMILIAR.
KEEP GOING, JOE RO!
>> SO RADICAL THAT THE RIGHT
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
CELEBRATING COMEDIANS AND
CELEBRATING CHAPPEL.
THEY HAD MY BACK THROUGH ALL
THE CRAZY [BLEEP] THAT
HAPPENED WITH ME.
IT WAS FOX NEWS THAT [BLEEP]
HAD MY BACK.
>> Greg: SO THIS IS THE
POINT I'VE BEEN MAKING SINCE
FOREVER OR AT LEAST SINCE
KAT TURNED 40 THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING IS THE BIG
FLIP WHEREAS THE LEFT
RETREATS INTO A WOKE COCOON
OF INTOLERANCE.
THE ONLY REAL DEFENDERS OF
ARTISTIC FREEDOM HAS TO BE
US, WHICH IS HARD, LIKE I
ALREADY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TO
DO TEACHING GLASS BLOWING TO
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
BUT IT WAS A PROMISE WE MADE
YEARS AGO THAT WE RIGHTIES
MUST SHARE THE RISKS WITH
LIBERALS WHO ARE UNDER
ATTACK, EVEN IF THEY HATE
US.
IF WE DEFEND THOSE WHO MAY
NOT CARE FOR US, WHETHER
IT'S ROGAN OR MAR OR
CHAPPELL, THEY MAY AT SOME
POINT SEE THE VALUE IN THE
MISSION BECAUSE SHARING RISK
IS ALL WE HAVE IN THE BATTLE
FOR OUR FREEDOM.
IT'S ALSO THE RIGHT THING TO
DO, AND IT'S SOMETHING WE
KNOW FIRSTHAND HERE HAVING
ENDURED THE SAME TREATMENT
FOR DECADES.
NO ONE KNOWS BETTER THAN US,
BOYCOTTS, CANCEL CULTURE.
I'VE BEEN THERE.
THE INSULTS, THE NAME
CALLING, THE THREATS OF
VIOLENCE, THAT'S JUST WHAT I
GREAT GERALDO.
WE'LL HAPPILY DEFEND OTHERS
EVEN IF THEY MAY STILL
SUBORNLY CLAIM TO BE LIBERAL
AND THEY MAY HATE US.
DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY NEED US MORE THAN WE
NEED THEM BECAUSE YOU'LL SEE
THE LEFT SPLIT EVEN FURTHER
INTO WARRING FACTIONS IN
WHICH ONLY ONE SIDE IS
REALLY WARRING AND THE OTHER
SIDE IS SIMPLY LEAVING.
IT'S LIKE A SPOUSE DIVORCING
A SUPER CRAZY PARTNER.
MEANWHILE, AS THE LEFT MAKES
HUMORLESSNESS HYSTERICAL,
THE RIGHT LOSES ITS SCOLD
AND REPLACES THEM WITH
FUN-LOVING SICKOS.
WE GO FROM JERRY FALWELL TO
THIS.
WHICH ONE WOULD YOU RATHER
HAVE YOUR KIDS GROW UP LIKE?
ALL RIGHT, BAD EXAMPLE.
AND NOT BECAUSE ONE IS DEAD
AND THE OTHER ONE IS DEAD
INSIDE.
WE ARE NOW THE PARTY OF
FREEDOM AND THE PARTY OF
SPEECH.
IN FACT, WE'RE JUST THE
[BLEEP] PARTY!
BECAUSE OVER THERE ON THE
OTHER SIDE, IT'S NO PARTY AT
ALL.
FUN IS ERODING FASTER THAN
JOE BIDEN'S FRONTAL LOBES.
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN YOU
THROW AWAY FREE SPEECH,
OTHER FREEDOMS FOLLOW.
AND SO DOES THE FUN, PEOPLE!
SO DOES THE FUN!
BY OFFERING YOUR HAND TO THE
PEOPLE BEING ATTACKED, THEY
OFTEN COME AROUND.
YOU CAN STILL DISAGREE ON
MANY THINGS, BUT THERE'S ONE
THING YOU COULD NEVER
ABANDON AND THAT'S YOUR
RIGHT TO SPEAK AND YOUR
ABILITY TO SHARE IT.
SO YOU'RE WELCOME, JOE.
HAPPY TO HELP?
WE'LL PAT OURSELVES ON THE
BACK FOR HAVING YOURS.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS!
SHE'S SO EVIL, DANTE HAD A
CIRCLE OF HELL MADE JUST FOR
HER, FOX NEWS @ NIGHT ANCHOR
EVIL SHANNON BREAM.
HE'S THE ONLY CASH NOT
ACCEPTED BY HUNTER BIDEN,
FORMER WHITE HOUSE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL AID AND
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK, "THE
FLAUNT AGAINST THE KING."
[INDISCERNIBLE]
SHE'S LIKE A KITE, COLORFUL,
BRIGHT AND HANGING ON BY A
THREAD, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
KAT TIMPF.
WHEN HE BUILDS A SAND CASTLE
ON THE BEACH, IT'S PUT ON
THE MARKET, WORLD NATIONAL
CHAMPION TYRUS.
SHANNON, HOW ARE YOU?
>> EXCELLENT!
>> GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON OUR
SHOW AS ALWAYS.
A PLEASURE.
>> PLEASURE'S MINE.
>> Greg: IT SHOULD BE.
>> YEAH.
>> Greg: WOULD YOU AGREE I
PLAYED THE MAIN PART IN
BRINGING JUSTICE TO JOE
ROGAN?
AM I THE REAL HERO HERE?
>> IF YOU SAY SO, YOU ARE.
I WANT TO SEE YOU GUYS DO A
PUSHUP CONTEST.
THEN I'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION.
>> Greg: ISN'T IT
INTERESTING HOW FOX -- FOX
IS ANTI-CANCEL CULTURE
PROBABLY BECAUSE WE KNOW
PEOPLE SCREW UP AND WE ALLOW
FOR SECOND CHANCES, AND
THAT'S KIND OF THE ANTIDOTE
FOR EVERYTHING, RIGHT?
>> WE ALL NEED THAT.
ONE INTERESTING CONVERSATION
-- ANOTHER THING ON ANY OF
THE SHOWS YOU WATCH, YOU'LL
HEAR FROM MULTIPLE SIDES.
YOU DON'T JUST GET BEAT OVER
THE HEAD FROM ONE SIDE OR
HAVE EXPLORATION OF IDEAS
AND NOTHING ELSE.
BILL MAHER IS GREAT ON THIS,
TOO.
WHEN YOU CLOSE IT DOWN, IT
JUST GETS UNINTERESTING AND
I THINK WE GOT IT BACK.
YOU SPECIFICALLY BROUGHT IT
BACK.
I GIVE YOU CREDIT.
>> Greg: I'VE GOT
EVERYBODY'S BACK.
>> AND SOMETIMES FRONT.
>> Greg: YES, THAT IS
TRUE.
SHE'S LEARNING.
EVIL SHANNON BREAM.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
CHILDREN'S BOOK.
>> I BROUGHT YOU A COPY.
SHANNON GETS A COPY.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU'RE
STRETCHING IT CALLING IT A
BOOK, THOUGH.
>> IT'S OVER 20 PAGES WHICH
IS YOUR LIMIT.
>> Greg: THAT'S NOT EVEN
THE LENGTH OF MY MONOLOGUE.
>> IT'S GOT COLORFUL
PICTURES IN IT.
>> Greg: DID YOU DO THE
ARTWORK?
>> YEAH.
>> Greg: NO YOU DIDN'T!
THIS IS A SCAM!
YOU ARE CRAZY.
>> BEST SELLER AND GOOGLE
SUPPRESSED IT TODAY.
THEY CRUSHED THE ENTIRE AD
CAMPAIGN.
>> Greg: REALLY?
THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'LL HELP YOU.
THEY CALL THAT THE STREISAND
EFFECT.
IT'S TRUE.
YOU'RE LAUGHING BUT THAT'S
WHAT THEY CALL IT.
I DIDN'T NAME IT ANY WAY,
ISN'T IT INTERESTING THIS
WHOLE FLIP?
LIKE IT'S THE RIGHT -- I'M
OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER THAT
THE RIGHT WAS LIKE THE
DEWORMER.
THEY WERE THE PEOPLE THAT
HATED SPEECH AND HATED
COMEDY.
IT'S COMPLETELY FLIPPED AND
NOW THE LEFT IS THE NEW
MORAL MAJORITY.
DO YOU FIND THAT STRANGE?
COMFORTING?
WEIRD?
WILL YOU WRITE A CHILDREN'S
BOOK ABOUT IT?
>> IT'S MY SEQUEL.
I'LL PUT GANDOLF THE GREAT
IN IT.
IT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN
GOVERNMENT.
I SPENT MY LIFE IN IT.
NOW I'M TRYING TO MAKE
MONEY, AND YOU'RE NOT
HELPING.
BASICALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS
GOVERNMENT GOES, OH, WE'RE
GOING TO DO AN
OVERCORRECTION.
YOU KNOW, CRIME IS TOO HIGH,
SO LET'S JUST BURY
EVERYBODY, AND EVERYBODY IS
GETTING SICK, SO LET'S
INOCULATE EVERYBODY.
AND THE LEFT IS DOING THE
EXACT SAME THING WITH THE
MEDIA AND NOW THEY DON'T
REALLY HAVE -- MY FORMER
BOSS, THEY DON'T HAVE HIM TO
KNOCK OVER THE HEAD.
THEY LOST THAT BLUDGEONING
PEN.
THEY SAY, WE HAVE TO KEEP
GOING.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO STOP.
OLD SCHOOL GUYS LIKE BILL
MAHER ARE GONE.
THEN YOU HAVE JOE ROGAN.
ONLY PEOPLE I HAVE WITH JOE
ROGAN IS THEY PUT ON THE
FAKE INDIAN DOCTOR AND THEY
COULD HAVE HAD A BOLWOOD
DOCTOR ON.
I MAY -- BOLBYWOOD DOCTOR
ON.
I MAY DECLINE IF HE ASKS ME
TO COME ON.
>> Greg: TRUMP LEFT THE
TRUMP-SHAPED HOLE -- CALL
BACK TO NIRVANA -- BUT ANY
WAY, THAT THEY TRIED TO FILL
WITH ROGAN AND THEN THEY
TRIED TO FILL IT WITH
TUCKER.
NOW, I BELIEVE THEY'RE
TRYING TO FILL IT WITH ELON
MUSK.
THEY KEEP THINKING HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO DO THIS?
TYRUS, YOU KNOW WHAT IS
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS
CONFLICT BETWEEN A LIBERAL
LIKE JOE ROGAN AND THE LEFT
IS THAT THEY CAN'T GET HIM
DOWN, SO THAT'S WHY.
IF YOU HAVE TO ADHERE TO
EVERY SINGLE POINT THAT THEY
BELIEVE OR YOU'RE OUT OF THE
CLUB, SO IF THEY CAN'T PIN
YOU DOWN -- LIKE, YOU AND I
DON'T AGREE ON A LOT OF
THINGS, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T AGREE
ON MY PLANS FOR TONIGHT.
>> NO.
>> Greg: FOR EXAMPLE.
>> WHICH IS WHY I'M NOT
PARTICIPATING.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO
SURPRISE YOU, THOUGH.
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
I NEVER GIVE THE ADDRESS OF
WHERE I'M STAYING.
IT'S NOT EVEN THAT THEY --
THEY ALWAYS SWING UP,
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T LOSE.
YOU ATTACK AN INSTITUTION
LIKE JOE ROGAN OR ATTACK AN
INSTITUTION LIKE PRESIDENT
TRUMP, WHAT'S THE WORST
THING THAT COULD HAPPEN?
YOU GET HIS ATTENTION.
AND WHEN YOU GET HIS
ATTENTION, WHAT HAPPENS?
YOU GET A LOT OF ATTENTION
AND YOU MAKE MONEY.
AND THE EASIEST WAY TO MAKE
MONEY IS PUNCH AT SOMEONE
ELSE'S SUCCESS.
IT'S CANCEL CULTURE.
SOMEONE WHO CAN'T GO AFTER
SOMETHING THAT CAN, AND THEY
FIND THE SMALLEST THING --
THEY DON'T TAKE HIM TO COURT
OR SUE HIM SAYING THEY
DEFAMED HIM OR HURT THEIR
FEELINGS SO THEY GO TO THE
SOCIAL MOB AND CANCEL
SOMEBODY AND SAY -- BRING UP
SOMETHING THEY DID, TAKE
KEVIN HART FOR EXAMPLE, TAKE
SOMETHING HE DID, APOLOGIZED
FOR AND NEVER DID AGAIN,
THEY WANT HIM TO
RE-APOLOGIZE FOR.
WHEN HE DIDN'T, THEY GOT
WHAT THEY WANTED.
THEY RUINED THE ECONOMY
ENOUGH.
THE ECONOMY DOESN'T NEED
MUCH MORE HELP TO GET RUINED
BUT THEY TOOK A GREAT
COMEDIAN FROM IT.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T DO IT.
GOING AFTER MUSK OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR ANYONE
WHO'S DONE IT OR MADE IT IS
A TARGET.
CONGRATULATIONS, KING OF
NIGHT.
THEY'RE COMING AFTER YOU
NEXT.
>> Greg: WHAT CAN THEY SAY
ABOUT ME THAT I'VE NOT
ALREADY SAID ABOUT MYSELF
THAT'S EXTREMELY DISGUSTING?
>> DEPENDS WHAT TIME OF THE
DAY THEY CALL US.
>> Greg: IT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING, THOUGH.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS THING
ABOUT SHARING THE RISK.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF
THIS.
IT SHOULD BE ABOVE -- I
THINK AS LEFT AND RIGHT FALL
APART, THAT'S ALL THAT'S
GOING TO BE LEFT IS THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE SANE VERSUS
INSANE PEOPLE.
>> YEAH, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
THE STANDARDS THAT, YOU
KNOW, THEY EXPECT PEOPLE TO
STICK TO, NOBODY CAN ADHERE
TO THAT, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
WE ALSO HAVE PEOPLE -- BRING
UP KEVIN HART BUT YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE GOTTEN
CANCELED OVER THINGS THEY
TWEETED 10 YEARS BEFORE WHEN
THEY WERE TEENAGERS.
THERE WAS THAT WOMAN THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE EDITOR OF
VOGUE.
INSENSITIVE TWEETS ABOUT
ASIANS SHE ALREADY
APOLOGIZED FOR.
SHE HAS TO RE-APOLOGIZE FOR
IT.
SHE WAS NEVER ABLE TO START
THAT JOB EVEN THOUGH YOU
FIND OUT ONE OF THE WOMEN
WHO WAS LEADING THE CHARGE
TO CANCEL HER, SHE HAD OLD
TWEETS WHERE SHE WAS USING
THE N-WORD!
NOBODY -- EVERYBODY MAKES A
MISTAKE AT SOME POINT AND
IT'S REALLY UNFAIR -- OR
IT'S ACTUALLY JUST STUPID TO
SAY A SINGLE COMMENT IS A
SNAP SHOT THAT CAN
INCAPSULATE AN ENTIRE
PERSON, BECAUSE WE'RE ALL A
LOT MORE COMPLEX THAN THAT.
>> Greg: ARE WE, THOUGH?
>> SOME OF US.
NOT EVERYBODY.
>> Greg: WE'RE LIKE
PRECIOUS SNOWFLAKES.
>> WHAT?
>> Greg: WELL, I MEAN --
THEY DON'T ALL HAVE TO BE
WHITE.
>> YOU KNOW HE AND I ARE NOT
WHITE, RIGHT?
>> Greg: IT WAS MEANT TO
BE THE UNIQUENESS OF A
SNOWFLAKE, OK?
>> WHAT'S A CREEPY SNOWFLAKE
LOOK LIK